Безлюдні вулиці та покинуті будинки, які вже 37 років занепадають без своїх господарів.
З кожним днем Чорнобиль дедалі більше перетворюється на дикі хащі.
Офіційно Чорнобиль - місто зі статусом "без населення".
Але люди тут все ще живуть - це самосели. Приміром, ось у цьому заквітчаному подвір'ї мешкає Михайло Шилан.
Добрий день!
Доброго здоров'я!
Пану Михайлу - вісімдесят п'ять. Третину свого життя він прожив тут…
Миру. Вулиця Миру, 47.
Здавалося, що після аварії на ЧАЕС нова біда не ступить на ці землі.
Але з початком повномасштабного вторгнення РФ сюди прийшли російські загарбники.
24 лютого 2022 року в окупацію потрапила АЕС, а невдовзі - й саме місто Чорнобиль.
Тут у мене були герб і український прапор, а кацапи приїхали сюди,
так я позафарбовував за день до їхнього приходу.
Як-небудь позафарбовував.
Злякався, а раптом прийдуть і розстріляють мене ні за що.
Зафарбував!
Росіяни оселилися в сусідньому будинку, за яким вже багато років доглядає пан Михайло.
Ідуть у цю хату. Я кажу: "Хлопці, я вам ключі дам". А вони: "Нє надо нам ваші ключі".
Автоматом тим, тими прикладами повибивали замки, повибивали двері, перевернули все на світі.
Пану Михайлу складно навіть пересуватися, не те, що захищатися. Утім, рідної домівки не покинув.
Звісно, боявся. Ну, діти мене забирали, але я принципово не пішов, а що вони мені зроблять? Хай уб'є.
Дідусь і гадки не мав, що знову переживатиме війну. Адже колись Друга світова забрала в нього дитинство.
Пан Михайло навіть створив імпровізований історичний музей на своєму подвір'ї. Це головна гордість господаря.
Вони їли консерви. Ну, щоб у вас було уявлення: 1943 рік. Можете показати, потримати.
Усі експонати пан Михайло збирав власноруч. Переважно після паводків на берегах річок Прип’ять та Уж.
Зараз я не можу вже активно жити, а то раніше я їздив по гриби, рибу ловив, то за цей час і назбирав.
Це буржуйка. Я її знайшов на березі річки Прип'ять під Ляльовим. Там я ловив рибу з вудкою і знайшов. Бачте?
Серед експонатів є й найдорожчі серцю речі, зовсім не пов'язані з війною.
Моя Паша Романовна - любительниця робити ось такі бездєлушкі.
Паша Романівна - покійна дружина самосела. У двотисячному році подружжя вирішило повернутися доживати віку у рідному Чорнобилі.
Я на 10 років молодшу жінку взяв, щоб на чужих дівчат не дивиться. А вона заболіла тією поганою хворобою й вмерла. Уже я майже 15 років сам.
Це моєї Паши Романовни, моєї жінки. Квіточки вона посадила. Я вже так і доглядаю.
Пан Михайло з особливим трепетом розповідає про все, що пов'язано з покійною дружиною.
І дуже просив показати глядачам Дойче Веллє квіти, які посадила його покійна дружина.
Знаєш, донька. Познімайте мої квіточки. Це ж вам буде фон. Давай, вперед.
Втрату дружини він переживає й досі. Тож для нього справжнім шоком стала поведінка російських військових, які залізли… в домовину.
Як вмерла моя жінка - я замовив труну в Чорнобилі. А діти привезли з Києва іншу труну.
І та труна своїть у тому хліву.
І та кацапня того гроба перевернули, відкрили. Що вже можна шукати в тому гробу - я не знаю…
Що він шукав у гробу? Певно, смерть свою шукав.
Після пережитого пан Михайло певен: тепер ніщо не вижене його з рідної оселі.
І скільки б діти не намагалися його забрати до себе - самосел рішуче відмовляється.
З моїм характером і моїми болячка - кому я треба? Вони мене забирають, але я не хочу.
- А що вас тут тримає так сильно? - Мої квіточки… Моя Паша посадила квіточки. Ото все вона попротягувала. Мене це тримає.
Нині в Чорнобилі мешкає близько пів сотні самоселів.
Переважна більшість з них - літнього віку. Це люди, які пережили аварію на Чорнобильській АЕС, евакуацію, але все одно,
попри заборону жити на цих територіях, вирішили повернутися.
Це ж мій Чорнобиль. Я заради нього й приїхала. Може, я й не жила б…
Тому що я зрозуміла, що без нього не виживу. І ніщо й ніколи мені не замінить…
Якщо я на день їхала в Київ чи ще кудись, то мені здавалося, що з моїм Чорнобилем щось сталося…
Саме тому через десять років після аварії на ЧАЕС Валентина Кухаренко повернулася до рідного Чорнобиля.
І навіть росіяни, які торік прийшли з війною, не змусили літню жінку покинути домівку.
Пані Валентина вірила, що українські військові визволять Чорнобиль.
Тому, каже, за своє життя навіть не хвилювалась.
За своє не боялися. А боялися за… Ось летять ракети, ми їх рахуємо: дев'ять штук, одинадцять.
Це ж ми знали, що полетіли й що чиєсь життя закінчиться. Ми плакали з донькою. А за себе якось не боялися.
Понад місяць окупації самосели прожили без води, світла, зв'язку й під постійним прицілом російських снайперів.
Ось на цій будівлі лежали снайпери. Проходити, звісно, було дуже страшно.
Вони цілими днями там лежали. Ну, дякуючи Богу, все обійшлося. Просто треба ще жити, напевно.
Спогади про окупацію даються пані Валентині нелегко.
Прикро…Бережіть себе всі!
Плакати хочете знову?
Так.
Чому?
Та весь світ… Шкода всіх.
Війна Росії проти України вже торкнулася її родини.
У дружини мого онука рідний брат загинув 5 березня. Жодних повідомлень.
Лише повідомили, що вони не повернулися із завдання.
Він був десь на фронті?
У Бахмуті...
Попри все у свої 84 пані Валентина вірить у перемогу України й мріє дожити, щоб побачити її на власні очі.
А для антистресу від жахіть війну - завела котів. Кожен з них має окреме ліжко й постійну увагу господині.
Лягай так, як ти можеш… Так-так… Ось так, добре.
З кожним роком самоселів у Чорнобильській зоні стає дедалі менше.
Але не тому, що тутешні мешканці звідси виїжджають.
Вони настільки прив'язані до цієї землі, що - попри радіацію і окупацію - обрали доживати свій вік у місті, яке вже майже зруйноване.